staggering 53 and a half million people
are expected to travel for the holiday
that's up 13 percent from last year in
the depths of the pandemic we have team
coverage of this at noon bianca holman
is looking at a very busy day at
mccarran airport but we start with
hector mejia watching the roads with
nevada state police hector good
afternoon
good afternoon well nevada and
california have joined forces working to
make sure everyone makes it to the
thanksgiving table and back home safely
right now you're taking a look at the
increased enforcement here along i-15
this is happening along or between saint
rose parkway and the prim area a
corridor that is known to be deadly
this week so far we've already had
multiple fatalities on the 15 freeway
when you watch it on the news it's just
a number but that number is somebody's
mom that's somebody's dad that's
somebody's son or daughter a
collaboration between california highway
patrol and nevada state police means
extra enforcement on the i-15 they're
watching for high speeds impaired
distracted and reckless driving on both
sides of the state line a chp airplane
will also launch from the sky this
thanksgiving week we are going to see
traffic delays and we just please ask
everybody to please have patience we
went along as officers and troopers went
out chp lieutenant todd kovelet says
he's seen a lot on the road it's one
little mistake one time speeding you're
going to save two minutes or you could
kill a family during busy holiday
weekends troopers also say they
oftentimes find drivers taking advantage
of the emergency shoulder the shoulder
is meant for emergency vehicles as well
as disabled vehicles maybe someone's
having a medical episode please
drive safely out there
enjoy your time with your family
and get home safe
that's the main message this afternoon
on average we're told 45 thousand cars
travel through that corridor that number
could easily double this holiday weekend
reporting on the i-15 hector mejia live
local now